hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today are gonna
be going over the Levin fish attack my
goal is to have the most in-depth
analysis that exists of the Levin fish
attack it is my favorite way to attack
the dragon variation in the Sicilian
offense so any player out there that
starts out with E 4 you're probably
gonna get met with the Sicilian offense
and that is C 5 and if you get met
against the Sicilian offense you need to
have a strong repertoire of how you're
going to attack that there's so many
dangerous lines that black can play here
Knight to f3 then you see the dragon
defense which is d6 d4 pawn to exchange
in the center of the board after Knight
takes on d4 Knight to f6 Knight c3 and
then pawn g6 preparing to bring the
bishop here to g7 and attack this long
dark square diagonal that white has on
the Queen side of the board so this is
the dragon variation if you're not
familiar with it you definitely should
make sure that you do some preparation
for this have a separate video on the
Sicilian defense dragon variation but
the Levin fish attack looks at this
position and says we need to be pretty
aggressive and we want to stop the
threat immediately of g7 and what's the
best way to do that and Levin fish
attack is f4 and I'll show you in just a
minute when we look at the variations of
why f4 is so good against the b2 the
Bishop to g7 square the three lines that
we are going to look at today one is
that Bishop to g7 the second one is
Knight to c6 which is becoming more and
more popular and the last one is Knight
to d7 now there are some other weird
variations you could see pawn down to e5
you could see Queen - maybe c7 those
just I don't see those very often this
is that main line that I play against
the dragon variation and I have quite a
few lines that I do want to cover in
those three so that's we're gonna be
covering today in the 11 fish attack the
first vation that we will look at is
Bishop to g7 this is the main idea that
Black has when they play the dragon
variation so many players
with a preparation they don't really
think too much about where White's gonna
go they're always gonna be playing
Bishop to g7 I'm saying it's a terrible
move I don't recommend it if you are
playing the dragon variation and you run
against white playing the eleven fish
attack simply because II 5 is just so
difficult to deal with now the correct
way to respond to this is Knight to h5
doesn't look like a great move and it's
not really fantastic but we'll look here
in a minute of why if you try to do
something pawn takes here on e5 that's
just not going to be as strong of a move
so Knights to h5 and then we have the
Bishop to b5 here checking the king now
you don't want to block it with your
Knights here Knight to c6 we can see is
a clear mistake Knight takes pawn takes
and then the bishops going to fork this
is check and it's going to take this
rook here on a eight same as if the the
knight wants to come here to d7 first
off this is blocking this Bishop here on
a c8 from from getting involved but now
pawns who e6 is very very difficult to
deal with you can see it's already
attacking this night the night can't
move so really the only way to stop that
is the pawn taking here anytime you
feeling Quetta to one side of the board
meaning bring your new bishop here to g7
for black you definitely don't want to
give up your F pawn this is a very
weakened King side of the board now a
sudden white can play Knight takes here
on e6 this is attacking both the bishop
here on a g7 as well as the Queen
maybe the bishop takes down here on c3
check really the only in-between move
that they have pawn takes here on c3
maybe Queen to a5 got to get out of the
way from the attack here but then white
just has Queen to d4 protecting both the
pawn right here and it's hacking this
rook here on h8 you can tell have this
King in the center of the board white
can a castle on the King side the board
still has a pretty safe King black on
the other hand his King is in the center
the board White's gonna be able to chase
that all over town so that's kind of not
going to be the way to defend it as well
if we do get into this setup really the
only way that black has to respond this
correctly is going to be Bishop here to
d7 there's a few ways that you can
attack this I've seen some pea
recommend just playing ecigs for my own
experience playing against this it
doesn't really matter if Bishop takes
here on b5 or even pawn takes here on e6
I don't think either those are as strong
as just playing queen - e - this does
defend this Bishop here on b5 this
defends the center of the board here it
still is attacking over here on the the
Queen side or the keep the King side of
the board also if you want to start
pushing with g4 at some point it
supports that as well so Queen to e2 is
my recommendation in this board and so
there's a few variations from here that
I'm gonna look at just because this is
the main line that I tend to see the
most when I am met with g7 because we
already looked at the Knights aren't
going to be moving to c6 or d7 so
they're almost always going to be
playing Bishop here to d7 I'm always
gonna be responding here with Queen to
e2 now from here there's a few moves you
could see from black a6 is pretty common
in the Sicilian defense specifically one
this is gonna bring the bishop back why
it's gonna come back here to c4 but it
also stops then white knights from
advancing you always want to be stopping
your opponent's Knights from advancing
up the board you know with bishops they
can control so much and get so many
places very quickly you can't stop them
as easily as you can with the Knights
the Knights have very few squares they
can go to especially as they're marching
up the board and there's pawns you can
see that the b v square especially for
white is a very critical square so a6
very common in the Sicilian defense in
this case Bishop back here to c4 and
then you could see a few options from
here maybe e6 in that case just castle
on the Kings side pretty good setup for
white here if they don't play you 6 you
could see maybe Queen to b6 attacking
the Knights I'm gonna bring the knight
back here to f3 solid set up this is
very similar to the Kings game and if
you were to castle on the King side you
have your pawn up here on f4 in this
case it hasn't been taken Knight to f3
you have Center control but it does
maintain pressure on this E
five square if you try something else
maybe night to be three you can still
eventually get that material back but
right away you are going to Toulouse
summons here whether you take the pawn
here or you force the the Queen back and
then you take and they recapture here
you're gonna be down a pond you're gonna
be fighting back I just don't think that
you have to play that instead if they're
attacking your knight just bring the
knight back here to f3 still a great
square protecting this you have both
your pawn your knight in your queen
still defending this square here on e5
very very critical square e five this is
also blocking off this Bishop coming
down here and attacking right away on
the c3 square so that's if they play
Queen to b6 another option is if they
just decide to take it in the center of
the board that's fine recapture right
here whites in a good setup you can
start to castle on the King side so a
lot of different options here you always
have surprise attacks depending on where
you're at maybe castle on the Kings side
you can play Bishop takes on f7 if
they're not prepared for it
it's gonna be defended by the rook here
on f1 so a lot of attacking lines that
White has now if we come back and say
doesn't have to play a six another
option could just be take here on e5
that's great I would go ahead and take
right here maybe they play Queen to c7
attacking this pawn same things before
I'm bringing the knight back here to f3
you don't always have to be attacking
although I am looking for attacking
lines generally when I'm playing chess
but sometimes it's better to just bring
your pieces back build up a strong
attack and then push forward depending
on where your opponent goes nine to f3
makes a lot of sense right here you can
always get your dark square Bishop
involved into the game castle on the
Queen side of the board but you know I'm
gonna be castling on the King side in
this setup here another option if they
don't take in the center of the board
right away is they could just take the
bishop right here from here I'm gonna go
and take with my queen you can't take
with your Knights but this immediately
puts your opponent into check kind of
puts them to the test right away Knight
to d7 pretty common in this case same
thing as before Knight to f3 well this
isn't this Knight is being pinned down
to the King right here eventually blacks
going to be able to castle
the kingside that's gonna free up
tonight tonight is attacking this
critical square and they're the board on
e5 so this Queen although it's attacking
the king also putting another pressure
point on e5 also attacking this pawn
here on b7 so a lot of different threats
that black has to deal with from that
very early setup of Queen to e2 that's
why I really like putting the Queen City
two there early in the game so we just
looked at all the variations if black
plays Knight to h5 which is the
preferred move they should go there it's
not a great move but that's where they
should be going but they could decide to
just take here on e5 not really a strong
move from black because they're
immediately giving up their central
control especially of this a 5-squared
critical square in the dragon variation
and if they give that up right away well
now they're in a pretty tough spot if
they come to h5 same as before not a
great square for this Knight right here
y can get pretty aggressive Bishop to b5
check preparing a castle on the King
side maybe Bishop to d7 but then pawn g4
and black is out of squares can't come
here to g3 because it's defended by the
pond can't come here to f4 defended by
the bishop right here yeah you can
always take this pawn in the center of
the board but then the Knights gonna
fall here on h5 it's gonna start
chipping away on the Kings side of the
board King doesn't have any safety
anymore how does that really continue
right here if you take yeah you can just
recapture right here so so many
different variations that black has to
do with at the end of the day that
they're definitely gonna be in a world
of hurt now they don't have to play
there Knight to h5 they could play
Knight to d7 says yeah I'm gonna just
gonna attack it from this standpoint but
I can just push forward put a lot of
pressure on them and depending on how
they want to continue they're gonna have
a tough position if they take right here
White's gonna recapture and then they're
they're putting so much pressure the
Queen are here on da it's under attack
the bishop here on g7 probably going to
take the knight here on C 3 because that
they have to give white double pawns but
that's fine Queen comes down here to a 5
and then Queen up here to d5 still has
to worry about this night here on e6
attacking the rook here on h8 Black's
just in a world
hurt by can still castle on the kingside
as well and if instead if they say okay
well I'm not going to do that instead
maybe they think something like Knight
to e5 okay well now I can just take here
on f7 that the King's gonna recapture
here and then Y can just attack the King
the rest of the game so that's why at
the beginning of the game you're
probably going to see if they play the
Bishop here to g7 you play e5 they're
probably gonna play h5 just know if they
don't though it is gonna be a mistake if
they do you're still gonna have a very
good game the next variation in the
Levin fish attack is going to be Knight
to c6 now I do see this a little bit
more than a Bishop to g7 these days but
there's not as many lines to go over
because many of them are forced in this
case I'm gonna take with my night here
on c6 and they're gonna recapture with
their pawn here on c6 so you can see
those are pretty much forced and then
I'm playing e5 right here so there are
some variations as far as where they
could go they could just immediately
take right here in that case I'm gonna
be playing Queen takes here on d8 then
the Queen takes here my pawns gonna take
you know a lot of different options as
far as where the knight goes maybe the
knight comes down here to g4 attacking
the pawn bishop here to f4 and this is a
setup on I'm gonna be completely fine
with when I say these specific setups if
you play these openings a lot I always
recommend especially players getting
into chess or trying to find a specific
opening find openings you like that you
have one fun playing with but you've had
good success and then play them over and
over and then find positions like this
and just study the board and figure out
what plan you want to attack and where
if your opponent goes one place where
would you go and so that's why I like to
look at these positions so this is
getting into the opening transitioning
into the middle game but this is
definitely a position I get into quite a
bit from here you can cast a lot to the
queen side of the board get your rook
involved to this D file right away your
opponent you can see here does not have
either of his bishop the bottom to the
game this is an open board stay right
here so both sides having the double
bishops
is going to be you know a pretty
aggressive game even though the queens
are off the board here if we come back
and say maybe the pawn doesn't take if
the pawn doesn't take the Queens are not
gonna come off the board right away and
that's completely fine as well another
move they could play is Knight to d7
this retreats the knight the Knights
under attack so that does make sense and
it also says yeah I can now attack this
pawn here on e5 if they do that I like
to play Queen to f3 very aggressive line
attacks this undefended pawn here on c6
and says yeah I don't really care if you
take right here I can recapture I can
always take here on a c6 pinning down
the night before that so a lot of
different options bring my bishop
involved into the game at some point
castle on the King side I always have
the option to castle on the Queen side
in this position I still am probably
gonna be castling more on the King side
so that's one option another option that
don't see too often but every now and
then you will see an opponent's played
Knight to g4 says hey yeah if you want
to attack my knight I'm just gonna
double attack your pawn here that's fine
though because h3 what are they really
going to do they're not gonna capture
here just going to capture with your
pawn they're gonna go down material
that's definitely a bad exchange so
they're gonna be playing Knight h6 I
assure you this is not a good square for
the knight at all and any time my
opponent plays a week's move like this
I'm gonna be pretty aggressive so Queen
to f3 as well get very aggressive here
you can see attacking this pawn right
here they're probably getting their
Queen involved into the game or Bishop
to b7 but they're still playing pretty
defensive here I can activate my pieces
night here on h6 again not doing it too
much so that's what happens if they
played Knight to c6 very common but
again pretty straightforward you're
gonna be taking and then it really just
depends on how they want to approach the
center of the board the last version we
are going to look at is Knight to d7
this does a few things one it defends
this night here on f6 which could be
attacked at some point it also adds
another defender to the critical square
of e 5 so if they want to play Bishop to
d7 push forward with e5 they have
another defender here in this case as
many times is I'm playing a very
aggressive
line here with 11 fish attack I'm going
to be pretty aggressive in this line as
well so I'm gonna be playing Queen to f3
I am later gonna be looking to get my
bishops involved into the game but I
really like playing that Queen to f3 now
they could decide immediately to attack
in the center of the board
pretty common in this case I'm gonna go
ahead and take they're probably gonna
recapture with their night they could
take with their pawn absolutely and then
we have to move our night out of the way
but they're usually gonna take with
their night because this is threatening
our queen here on f3 and says hey you
need to move that well I'm not gonna
move it right away instead I have an
in-between move Bishop to b5 check
they're probably gonna have to defend
this Bishop to d7 makes a lot of sense
I'm gonna take that right away I think
that's fine they're probably gonna take
with their night here on these seven I
say probably because hey if they want to
come back here to d7 I don't have to
worry about my queen right now I can
castle on the King side that's fine so
I'm going over the optimal moves yes
your opponent may be making mistakes and
you can look at that and say hey that's
that's not what they should be doing
maybe I don't have to play the the main
lines here and how can i exploit what
they are trying to do so we're generally
going to see Knight taking here on the 7
and if this is the case I would play
Queen to g3 and I feel like this is a
pretty good setup from here if they
wanted to continue you know you could
see Bishop to d7 Bishop to f4 now in
this case I'm probably gonna be looking
at castle on the Queen side of the board
very few times that I will be looking to
castle on the Queen side aboard other
times I'm looking to cast on the King
side because it's so easy for black to
come down take my knight here on C 3 and
then I recapture with my pawn here on c3
and it's not a very good queenside
castle but in this setup specifically I
found that castle e on the Queen side
does pretty good for white so that's
what happens if they push early on with
that pawn on e5 now they don't have to
do them instead another move that they
could play is a6 we talked about this
before pretty common in the Sicilian
defense this does stop both the knight
coming here to b5 as well as this one in
this case I'm going to be playing Bishop
to e3 in this position
Bishop coming here to d7 I
do you feel like because the Queen here
on f3 is no longer defending this night
it is nice to have another defender here
you can now castle on the Queen side if
you wanted to as well but Bishop to e3
is a pretty safe setup for white here
blast option is they could just decide
play Bishop to g7 this is the main theme
that you have in the dragon variation so
it makes a lot of sense just to go ahead
and play Bishop here to g7 same thing
Bishop here to e3 if they Castle on the
Kings side I'm gonna go ahead and castle
on at the Queen side and then it's
pretty much just an all-out attack I'm
gonna start pushing g4 here at some
point really start to chip away at their
King side of the board so let that is
the Levin of his attack again this is
the way that I like to attack the dragon
of variation I know a lot of other
players play this as well so if you
haven't tried it out I definitely
recommend it very very good winning
percentage from white just if you're
looking not only at just club level
players but if you're looking at
grandmasters for the last hundred years
white does very favourable so this is
not a f4 attack wow I don't know if
that's actually gonna do well this is a
very very strong attack but thank you
guys so much for watching the video
hopefully you enjoyed this in-depth
analysis of a variation in the dragon
variation if you guys liked the video if
you want mine liking it also feel free
to leave me a comment in the section
below trying to respond to those more
and more you can always reach me on the
website at the chest website.com you can
chat me on there you can always reach
out to me via email as well the chess
website at gmail.com but thank you guys
so much for watching and i'll see you in
the next video
you